und jetzt mal eine frage mit der man
sich wirklich ärger einhandelt sollte es
in deutschen innenstädten viel mehr
tempo 30 zonen geben gerade hat sich
auch noch stuttgart der initiative tempo
30 angeschlossen über 70 deutsche
kommunen wollen nach eigenem ermessen
ganze straßen entsprechend verlangsamen
können laut straßenverkehrsordnung
dürfen die das nämlich zurzeit nur auf
einzelnen abschnitten machen für die sie
dann auch noch eine besondere
gefahrensituation nachweisen müssen mit
genug unfällen verstehen sie wird wer
also mehr tempo 30 will muss erst mal
mehr unfälle bauen was womit ich in
keinem fall sagen will dass jedes tempo
30 schild sinn macht dieses tempo 30
schild amüsiert derzeit den ganzen
oberhausener norden eingerichtet hat es
die stadt wegen lärmschutz
ausgerechnet über der viel befahrenen
und sechsspurigen autobahn 2 ohne
tempolimit
ja natürlich lärmschutz damit man die
autobahn besser hört macht übrigens
trotzdem sind den kommunen hier mehr
entscheidungsfreiheit zu geben die groko
hat genau das schon vor zwei jahren
angedeutete also angedeutet sie können
sie sich das vorstellen aber seitdem ist
gar nichts mehr passiert dabei gibt es
eigentlich nur gute argumente für mehr
tempo 30 in der stadt stichwort
lärmschutz für die anwohner ist
eindeutig oder die sache mit der
luftqualität ein pilotversuch in berlin
hat gerade nachgewiesen dass tempo 30
die stickstoffdioxid werte teils
deutlich verringern kann meine sicher
was der bürger dann aus einem tempolimit
machte da steht natürlich auf einem ganz
anderen strafzettel ich weiß dass so
eine 30er zone ist ich bin habe ich
vorher dass die ampel rot umgesprungen
ist und ich glaube ich bin einfach nur
weiter ich bin nur 50 gefahren nicht ein
knappes ding ja ganz knapp
nicht mal das doppelte es ist schon
komisch dass wir bei tempolimit immer
nur aufgeregt über autobahnen streiten
und kaum über tempo 30 in der stadt denn
da ist der unterschied zum beispiel
zwischen 50 und 30 eben kein knappes
ding hälfte raus führerschein nach
prüfung wie viel länger ist der
anhalteweg also reaktionszeit plus
bremsweg bei 50 km h im vergleich zu 30
a baby einfach mehr als doppelt so lang
antwort war direkt mit eingeblendet nrw
abi niveau mit anderen worten tempo 30
ist zwar sicher eine gewöhnungssache
rettet aber leben von der sind auch
diese albernen langsamen dinge mit viel
zu wenig karosserie fußgänger genau oder
radfahrer deshalb ist 30 jahre in vielen
europäischen metropolen und in ganz
spanien längst die norm und eben nicht
die ausnahme auch in paris und die kommt
dass da so an
alle meine kollegen sagen und was soll
da ist vielleicht werden einige deswegen
ihr geschäft aufgeben 30 km h bei einem
fahrzeug das 260 wird das ist
unverstellt
oder wie louis de funes sagen würde
tempo 30
zum ausprobieren zum warmwerden könnte
man ja auf einigen großen
hauptverkehrsstraßen weiter 50 erlauben
der rest dann eher 30 aber auch das
konzept wird viele deutsche kaum
überzeugen denn hier geht es ja nicht
nur um fakten geht es um gefühle und das
muss man auch verstehen ich meine da
sind wir endlich da einen porsche
zusammen gespart und dann darf sie nicht
laufen lassen das macht natürlich
tierisch aggressiv
und dann kommt die ultimative demütigung
irgend so ein verletzter öko student auf
seinem laster machte ich gnadenlos nass
aber der trend ist klar
mittelfristig muss der homo sapiens sich
seine städte vom auto regelrecht
zurückerobern mehrere deutsche kommunen
experimentieren sogar schon mit komplett
kfz freien zonen
ich hoffe nur unsere karten kriegen das
nicht mit die teile sind heute voll
gestopft mit künstlicher intelligenz
dazu gehört also autofreie stadt das
könnten wir aber eindeutig zu weit die
spinnen ja wohl die grünen
gegen die uneingeschränkte einführung
von tempo 30 innerorts als
regelgeschwindigkeit ist unter anderem
auch der verband der automobilindustrie
die lobbyorganisation der autohersteller
wir schauen mal leicht zu claus von
wagner vom vdr forschungszentrum mehr
von wagner was erforschen sie denn da
auf ihrer teststrecke naja wir testen
gerade was das mit einem bmw macht wenn
er längere zeit 30 fährt herr welke das
deutsche automobil ist nie für tempo 30
konstruiert worden für so niedrige
geschwindigkeiten gibt es auch gar keine
datenlage wir wissen nicht mal was das
mit dem gehirn eines fahrers überhaupt
macht
und ich kann sich mit ansehen man möchte
hinlaufen und schieben wo man wofür
brauchen wir dann überhaupt noch
schnelle autos das ist es ist wie
rennpferde züchten sie dann in die
lasagne schmeißen das macht überhaupt
keinen sinn es gibt schon argumente und
taten pro tempo 30 die sache mit dem
lärm zb vor allem die rollgeräusche der
reifen reduzieren sich gefühlt um die
hälfte
das ist was gutes ich sage mal nicht
hören will was meine familie so erzählt
dann ziehe ich ausland
einer umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus die
echten gefahren lauern beim zu langsam
fahren oder in den worten eines
legendären ex verkehrsminister auf 6
traffic ausgebauten autobahnen mit quasi
null verkehr mit einschläfernden 120
oder 130 zu fahren das kann auch
hingefahren
ganz genau und wenn 130 auf der autobahn
schon gefährlich ist
rechnen sie das nochmal runter bei 30 in
der stadt bist du klinisch tot der
verband der spediteure waren zum
beispiel tatsächlich bei 30 würden noch
viel mehr fahrer am steuer aufs handy
gucken weil die aufmerksamkeit dann
generell abnimmt nein das ist fakt wir
haben dazu hier auch eigene studien
gemacht sobald man nur noch 30 fährt
fangen die probanden instinktive an
andere sachen zu machen einfache
laubsägearbeiten zum beispiel tierisch
gefährlich wieder andere mal nebenbei
aquarelle oder lackieren sich die
fußnägel fall ist ihnen bei tempo 30
schlichtweg zu langweiliges spiel sie
und der adac verbreiten schlichtweg
mythen über tempo 30 tatsache ist in
helsinki und oslo sind nach einführung
von tempo 30 im jahr 2019 keine
fußgänger oder radfahrer mehr ums leben
gekommen mehr argumente brauche ich doch
nicht ja klar das klingt erstmal positiv
für den laien aber als hobby jäger kann
ich ihnen sagen dann darf man sich
hinterher auch nicht wundern wenn die
population der radfahrer außer kontrolle
gerät das ist wie bei wildschwein wenn
man die nicht bejagt werden dass immer
mehr hast du denn herreweghe tempo 30
irgendwann ist auch mal gut autofahren
in der stadt ist ja jetzt schon eine
zumutung
[Musik]
also in der stadt jedenfalls nicht war
früher besser war für busse und woran
liegt das
jeder drei autos
wie schön dass er mal lachen kann
recht positiv denken man muss positiv
denken wahrscheinlich kommt die
regelgeschwindigkeit 30 am ende sowieso
nicht in meine wir vom vdh haben gerade
erst ein generelles tempolimit im ampel
vertrag verhindert und wir haben einen
fdp verkehrsminister
die ersten scherzkekse sagen sogar schon
dort gar nicht so schlecht
spaß beiseite da wären wir es schaffen
diesen schleich waren sind zu stoppen
auch leute nein es wird jetzt brennt der
motorwelle zu lange 30 gefahren ist
dafür ist jedoch nicht gebaut yahoo
gibt vollgas sonst verbrennt du claus
von wagner
[Musik]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen aber da